Something's coming.
Something dark.
I sense it.
This is a new beginning
for some
War. For others
power.
It's been a while.
Things have changed.
I started hearing whispers
about thrawn’s return
as heir to the Empire.
We have to prepare for the worst.
The jedi fell a long time ago.
There aren't many left.
Perhaps it is
time to begin again.
Welcome back
everyone. Happy Star Wars Celebration.
They just dropped the brand new Ahsoka
trailer, so we'll break it down.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
references.
We finally saw live action.
Grand Admiral Thrawn. For real.
There's a bunch of new Dark Jedi,
so I'll explain what's going on with them.
There's a whole bunch of connections
to The Mandalorian
because it's happening
during the same time period too.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes.
It premieres in August,
so be sure to subscribe to get them.
Dave Filoni wrote and directed
most of these episodes,
which is why he didn't work
on The Mandalorian Season three episodes
quite as much.
I believe he wrote a little bit
on the season
like he worked on Episode seven.
They're actually screening
that later tonight.
We're probably going
to get a Thrawn teaser
before the end of the season
in another Ahsoka teaser,
just pushing into that series,
but just starting at the beginning
of the trailer footage.
It starts with Ahsoka at this
abandoned Jedi temple at these ruins
where she encounters some of the
HK droids from Thrones seventh Fleet.
That was the whole idea,
is that Morgan Elsbeth,
who is the character that we see in
the trailer,
is going to be a big character
during the Ahsoka series.
A villain to her
is meant to be one of Thrones
followers who's been helping him
return from the unknown regions.
She has the key droids from Thrawn
seventh Fleet that has insignia on that.
That's how we knew
that she was connected to Thrawn.
And then obviously Ahsoka said at the end
of the episode, Where's your master?
Where's grand Admiral Thrawn?
That's who she's talking about
when she says something is coming.
She even literally says the words heir
to the Empire when talking about Thrawn,
confirming my theories since the beginning
of the Mandalorian season one
that they're doing a version
of the live action heir
to the Empire Series through the Ahsoka
series, The Mandalorian.
These are the connected series.
During the Mando verse
in this part of the timeline,
there'll be some different characters,
like they're substituting the Grogu
cloning plot
for the Luke cloning plot in the Heir
to the Empire Thrawn trilogy in the books.
But you'll see a lot of familiar things
if you read the original Thrawn trilogy.
If you haven't, it's fantastic.
I would recommend checking it out.
The whole vibe from the trailer pits.
This series is more of a wandering samurai
type of series.
The same vibe from Ahsoka's
Mandalorian Season two episode.
The tone of the series will be a lot
more like that.
Love the shot of her
using her twin lightsabers
to bore down into the chamber below.
That's meant to be a callback to the scene
at the end of the Clone Wars,
where she did the same thing,
escaping the other clones during Order 66
when it had just started.
You have to imagine that she's doing this
while Mando is with Grogu
helping the Mandalorians retake Mandalore.
Like it's all happening
around the same time.
One of the other big changes is the
Lucasfilm logo is pure red, which I think
is meant to be a reference to the Dark
Jedi that we see during the trailer.
The voice of Balan
talking about a new beginning is Rey
Stephenson's Dark Jedi character.
I believe he's meant to be a fallen Jedi
who survived Order 66
and since then
has turned to the dark side.
But he wasn't part of the Inquisitor,
as it does seem like a soldier fights
a former inquisitor
because the Dark Jedi is using
the double bladed lightsaber here.
Looks like an inquisitor blade.
But by this point in the timeline,
the inquisitor is don't exist anymore.
So any of the surviving inquisitors
that were still around would have just
been rogue Inquisitor
as we see live action Sabine Wren.
They actually showed us a preview of her
in her full Mandalorian armor.
Remember,
she's a Mandalorian from House Ren,
so that's why she might show up
by the finale of The Mandalorian.
Because all the mandalorians are supposed
to unite on the planet Mandalore.
But all the scenes of her,
for the most part in the trailer,
take place on Low Thul.
It's meant to be a reference
to the very end of Star Wars rebels.
I believe they're going to flashback
and we'll see a version of this scene
happening in live action
when assuming it comes to visit her.
And she's like, It's been a while.
I believe that's meant to be part of the
live action version of this scene here
that we already saw on Star Wars Rebels.
It was meant to happen right
after the events of Return of the Jedi,
whereas The Mandalorian Series
picks up about five years
after Return of the Jedi,
which is why I say
Ahsoka might jump around in the timeline
a little bit with a few flashbacks.
Ahsoka facing Morgan Elsbeth HK droids from
the Seventh Fleet, Thrawn Seventh Fleet.
These are meant to be the same force
of HK droids that you saw
during Mandalorian in season two.
It also seems like this dark Jedi
Balan has plans for the Galaxy as well,
might be connected to Thrawn, or Thrawn
might try to engage his services.
They might be substituting the Jaws Kibo
with character from the heir to the Empire
Thrawn trilogy for this Balan character.
He might be the stand in for that Jedi
master that goes a bit twisted
by the end of the Thrawn trilogy
in the original version
of the Thrawn trilogy
that George could both Jedi
master character
starts out being just a little bit weird
in his slowly goes crazier
and crazier and crazier and you find out
that he's also a clone as well.
But I don't think the Balan character
is meant to be a clone.
Like I said, I think he's just meant to be
a Jedi that survived Order 66
and has been twisted evil
since then and turn to the dark side.
The war that he's talking about
is more of a metaphor for Thrawn
returning in force with the Seventh Fleet,
but also the dark side of the
force resurging.
Then we get our first official
look at Mary
Elizabeth Winstead as the version of Hera
from Star Wars Rebels in the Ghost.
This is all meant to be characters
from Star Wars, rebels
in live action, basically like the sequel
to Star Wars Rebels, but in live action.
I believe they're also doing her son
Jason Sin Dula during the series as well.
He is force sensitive.
We might see some flashbacks
to cannon jars
or some references to him,
but he's dead in present day
and I don't believe he learned
how to become a force ghost.
So I'm not expecting to see him
show up as a force ghost.
If we see him, it'll be pictures of him.
Probably.
We see a live action chopper for anybody
who wondered
if he was going to show up on the series.
Then we see the actual Balan character
and his dark apprentice
who's being played by Ivana Sanko.
I don't know what
her name is on the series,
but she's just meant to be his dark
Jedi Padawan.
You see her attacking a New Republic ship.
Then we go back to Lothar.
You see Ahsoka ship here
from the end of Star Wars rebels,
like I said, picking up basically
where rebels left off in that same scene.
This is literally meant to be the same
tower that you see at the end of rebels.
It seems like
this is when Ahsoka comes back
at the end of rebels
to tell us to being okay.
It's time to find
what's going on with Grand Admiral Thrawn.
Time to find Ezra Bridger
in What happened at the end of Rebels
is that you basically end the series right
before the beginning of a new hope,
and then it jumps in time
to this scene here.
So when you're seeing Sabine Wren,
she's been through the Galactic Civil War.
She worked with the rebels
during that whole period.
That's
why she's wearing the leather jacket here.
It seems like she's
had some city miles on her because she's
just been through the original trilogy.
When Ahsoka says things have changed,
we see the New Republic Senate,
Monmouth, Emma
with a couple of the other newer senators
that are part of the New Republic,
slightly older, slightly wiser Monmouth
that we see during the Andor series.
When she says she started hearing
whispers, she's talking about Grand
Admiral Thrawn
because she goes on to talk about Thrawn.
We actually see the back of his head
with the blue skin.
The interesting thing here though, you see
the ship that he's on does not look like
a typical Imperial Star destroyer ship
that's part of his seventh Fleet.
So it seems like
he's picked up more forces.
But these might be the Dreadnoughts
from the heir to the Empire storyline,
the original Thrawn trilogy.
During that storyline,
one of the things that Thrawn is after,
more power that he's after is this
mysterious lost fleet of Dreadnoughts that
he thinks is going to beef up his forces
enough to take down the New Republic.
That might be the ships that he's on
right here with Morgan Elsbeth,
because you see her on these same ships
later.
It's meant to be a massive upgrade
in capital ships to his already Big
seven fleet.
Love the shout out from Ahsoka
saying heir to the empire,
confirming all of our theories
all these years about Theron's return
as heir to the Empire.
This is why during the Mandalorian season
three episode one, they showed you
the pergolas the space whales,
which are meant to be a callback to Ezra
Bridger and Grand Admiral Thrawn
being lost in the unknown regions.
Showing us the pergola again was meant
to represent that they had returned.
They had found a way back
on these new ships.
You actually see a couple of the Death
Star droids, the R.A.
seven droids.
We just saw those on The Mandalorian.
It seems like Morgan
Elsbeth will be one of the main antagonist
to Ahsoka, in addition to Ray Stephenson's
Balloon Dark Jedi character in Grand
Admiral Thrawn.
But really the main villain is Grand
Really cool details during this scene too.
Like obviously you see Ahsoka
fighting Bale in the dark jet
eye, really cool lightsaber fight
that people are going to have here.
But in the background of this Jedi temple,
these symbols that you see,
the energy looks like it's force energy
that you saw Grogu when he was on Titan.
But the symbols actually looked like
the same symbols from the world
between worlds, which are the same symbols
that make up the Ahsoka logo.
So we might actually
see a live action version of the World
between Worlds during the series.
That was basically a place in the force
that allowed people access to all points
in time in space.
Like you could basically travel through
time.
That's how Ezra Bridger wound up
saving Ahsoka during the fight
with Darth Vader
in an earlier season of Star Wars Rebels.
He basically joined her through space
and time.
It seems like Hera here is trying to warn
the New Republic leadership
about what's coming, and this is probably
related to Grand Admiral Thrawn.
We see the dark
AI Padawan in a dogfight with Ahsoka ship.
We see what looks like the beginning
of a really cool Darth Vader style hallway
scene with Balan's Jedi just ripping
through the New Republic in this hallway.
Don't want to be stuck in a hallway
with any Sith characters
or Luke Skywalker for that matter.
We finally get our first
look at Ezra Bridger when Sabine Wren
is looking at a hollow of him,
while Ahsoka is narrating
that there are very few Jedi left
because he is basically a Jedi trainee.
I don't know if you would call him
a full Jedi yet.
It's kind of like a Luke
Skywalker original trilogy situation
where Yoda said, Oh, Jedi, you're a Jedi.
Well, you're not quite one yet.
You still have a couple of tests you have
to confront Vader before that happens.
I have a feeling it'll be the same thing
with some of the characters
on this series, too.
A soldier has that cool fight
with what seems like a former inquisitor.
The only thing I would object
to during the trailer
is that they call her a Jedi
in the trailer.
Technically, Ahsoka is not a Jedi
because she left the Jedi order.
She's just a highly trained person,
a very powerful person in the force.
The same thing is true of Grogu
who he let the Jedi order,
but he's still training in the force.
Then we get a super deep cut.
This is meant to be
the same Jedi droid from the Jedi ship.
He had the designs of every single
lightsaber that had ever been created.
And I don't know
that this is meant to be a flashback,
but it seems like
it's still happening on Lethal
and if you remember,
it was the voice of David Tennant.
So I believe that David Tennant is coming
back to do The Voice for this series.
There's a lot of stealth voiceover
cameos in Star Wars.
I wonder how many people will spot this.
Most people who watch Clone Wars
will recognize them.
We might see some of the Mandalorian
characters like Mando and Grogu
who show up or cameo on the Ahsoka series.
Maybe Bo-Katan as well too, because
Bo-Katan has so much history with Ahsoka.
I believe going forward
there'll be more crossovers
between the characters
from the Mandalorian series in the saga
because we just saw Zeb from Star Wars
Rebels in Live Action in The Mandalorian.
He will also probably show up
on the Ahsoka series as well too.
Pretty much.
Most of the Star Wars
Rebels characters from The Ghost
are coming back in live action
through this.
Then we get the confirmation that
the Ahsoka episodes are coming in August.
It'll be towards the end of August,
but it'll be eight episodes,
just like The Mandalorian
looks like it's going to be total fire.
Obviously there's so much
that we don't know
about the series that like
this is just a taste.
They're calling it the teaser,
so I think we'll get a full trailer
by the time we get to the summer.
We also saw footage from Star Wars
acolyte Star Wars Skeleton Crew,
which is also meant to be a spinoff
of The Mandalorian
and connected
to the Ahsoka series as well.
But we won't see the Skeleton Crew series
characters on The Mandalorian.
But if you spotted any other Easter
eggs or references
during the trailer footage
that it didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Of course, I'll do more Ahsoka videos
when we get more footage
and obviously my Full Mandalorian Season
three Episode seven Video
or post next week after they release it,
we might get some more Ahsoka cameos,
maybe Sabine Wren to everyone.
Click here for that Mandalorian Season
three Episode seven Video and click here
for all My Mandalorian episodes.
Thank you so much for watching,
everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.